les entreprises sont elles prêtes à
transformer leurs flottes d'autos et de
camions pour des véhicules électriques
et les gouvernements doivent-ils en
faire davantage pour accélérer cette
transition avec nous ce soir sarah aux
deux pdg de propulsion québec la grappe
des transports électriques et
intelligent bonsoir mansart et samaa
quebecor vidéotron tva toute l'équipe de
quebecor a annoncé une stratégie
d'électrification de ses véhicules
ça fait jaser un peu est ce qu'il ya de
plus en plus d'entreprises comme ça qui
font ça absolument pour que le québec
devienne un leader mondial en transport
électrique et intelligence qui est notre
notre mission et notre objectif il faut
que le québec soit un client exemplaire
de nos propres produits pour qu'ensuite
on puisse les exporter à l'étranger et
quebecor est à cet égard un exemple et
l'otan qu'est ce qui l'a décidé dès les
cris de prendre l'engagement
d'électrifier toute sa flotte de
véhicules et il est là plusieurs sortes
de véhicules les plus petits des plus
gros donc des lectrices à sa flotte de
véhicules et avec une intention de
s'approvisionner au québec le plus
possible est ce qu'il ya comme quebecor
d'autres entreprises d'autres exemples
qu'on peut donner qui veulent électrifié
à 100% leur véhicule il ya un
comportement real qui a également pris
l'engagement et d'électrodes des
lectrices à flotte de véhicules ya
plusieurs autres entreprises
actuellement qui regarde ce qui est
disponible sur le marché
la saq par exemple acheter un camion
électrique cliente lui sera livré à la
fin de l'année pour entamer cette
transition l'a donc enlevé plusieurs
jeux qui sont là vraiment dans cette
démarche absolue pour vidéotron ses 14
millions de dollars d'investissement
pour électrifier toute la flotte de
vidéos temps mais la presse rapportait
que jusqu'à 5 millions de dollars
pourraient être payés par le
gouvernement du québec est ce que les
gouvernements doivent encore et encore
plus investir pour que cette transition
se fasse absolument cesser c'est une
condition sinequanone je vous dirai pas
ce que effectuer cette transition
écologique et technologique là c'est un
poids très important pour les
entreprises mais à la fois ça a un
impact très important sur les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre les véhicules
qui circulent aussi
une flotte ce sont des véhicules qui
circulent constamment si on gère bien sa
flotte on s'organise pour que son
véhicule soit constamment sur la route
donc et même des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre constamment ça c'est des
coûts importants pour pour trans transit
et finalement pour changer les véhicules
mais aussi installer toutes les
infrastructures de recharge pour former
ses employés dont il ya vraiment des
investissements importants qui sont
affamés qui rapporte beaucoup sur le
plan environnemental
et pour cela le gouvernement offre déjà
des programmes c'est cela dont vous
venez parler la portée des canons qui
vont faire appel aux programmes qui sont
disponibles pour tout le monde mais qui
sont déjà disponibles à toutes les
entreprises dont kim ont bénéficié de ce
que ce qui est déjà accessible à tout le
monde mais nous on pense que le
gouvernement devrait bonifier encore
davantage ses investissements cesser son
soutien au public pour appuyer les
entreprises qui finalement souvent on
s'approvisionner auprès de fournisseurs
québécois voilà donc là quelque part la
ccc c'est bon pour l'économie du québec
de d'effectuer cette transat c'est bon
pour l'environnement garde certains
diront que cet argent devrait davantage
le mettre dans le transport en commun en
transport collectif beaucoup plus que
dans la voiture le véhicule
le taux le camion électrique plusieurs
personnes ont précisé plusieurs
personnes disent que qu'on devrait
investir dans le transport collectif
plutôt que dans la subvention à l'auto
électrique solo ce qui est effectivement
une bonne chose pour nos membres qui
sont plutôt des manufacturiers de de
toutes sortes de véhicules à l'exception
de l'auto parce qu'au québec on ne gêne
on ne fait pas d'eux
deux véhicules
l'écurie passagers électriques ou à
essence électrique on n'en fait pas donc
en fait tout tout tout tout les autres
véhicules qui sont plutôt utilisés dans
le transport en commun donc oui nous
aussi on croit qu'on devrait investir
davantage dans le transport en commun
mais aussi dans les flottes de véhicules
commerciale car c'est comme je vous le
dis le elles émettent beaucoup de gaz
est fait à lille avec le québec produit
beaucoup de ces véhicules logan ont fait
des vélos électriques des trottinettes
électriques quoi d'autres ont fait bon
des autobus scolaires électrique des
autobus urbains de toutes tailles
électriques ont fait des véhicules
récréatifs comme des motoneiges
électriques ont fait également des
trains électriques des tramways
électriques
donc on fait finalement tout tout ce qui
dans le spectre l'art entre la
trottinette et le train électrique
on fait tout sauf des voitures
électriques chapeau qu'est ce qu'on
attend rend finalement quand on regarde
le transport électrique intelligent vous
avez sorti quelques données vous avez
travaillé sur des données avec la firme
kpmg valeur des ventes réalisées en 2010
9 2 milliards 200 millions de dollars
exportation 830 millions emplois directs
et relié au secteur 6240 emploi et les
véhicules électriques vont représenter
30% du parc automobile canadien d'ici
2030 soit 13 millions 200 mille
véhicules
est-ce qu'on peut encore améliorer
davantage le véhicule électrique
certains disent et rappelle que lors de
la conception du véhicule électrique et
beaucoup d'utilisation de deux de
matières minérales de ressources
minérales
est ce qu'on peut faire mieux bon
d'abord pour ce qui est de l'extraction
et des procédés
ce qui a trait à l'industrie minérale au
québec et au canada on a des noms très
élevé en comparaison de plusieurs pays
dans le monde donc ce qui esquisse qui
produit ici au québec et qui pourrait
potentiellement contribuer au
développement d'une chaîne de valeur
dans les batteries seraient
définitivement plus verte ailleurs
dernièrement deuxièmement est pour ce
qui est de l'art le cycle de vie d'un
véhicule électrique au complet un
élément qui pourrait significativement
améliorée améliorer la performance
environnementale serait de recycler les
batteries
actuellement on a développé au québec
des brevets très intéressant très
prometteur on a notamment une usine
pilote qui a ouvert ses portes en joue
et qui testent leur technologie qui
pourrait permettre d'extraire jusqu'à
95% de des composantes de la batterie à
un niveau grade batterie ce qui nous
permettrait vraiment de le réutiliser
dans la première heure de nouvelles
batteries est donc là on aurait à
utiliser l'extraction minéral que comme
complément finalement le à ce qu'on
pourrait réutiliser l'eau dans le
recyclage des batteries sera hôte merci
beaucoup avec mes amis aussi bien